welcome back to cbs this morning we're
to begin with the new focus of the
democratic presidential contest
and that focus of course is south
carolina an important moment
in the race for the party's nomination
gail king is in charleston
ahead of tomorrow's democratic debate
which of course is co-hosted by cbs news
bernie sanders the party's current
national front runner is looking to
widen his lead
after a decisive victory in saturday's
nevada caucus his challengers
are trying to build some kind of
momentum going into next week's
super tuesday showdown let's go straight
to gail now
in south carolina gail good morning good
morning to you both the debate will be
held inside the building right behind me
this is the gill yard center
this is the last time the candidates
will make their case to a national
audience before saturday's primary here
in south carolina
so a lot of people are paying more
attention to this one and super tuesday
too
which is one week from tomorrow seven
candidates will be on stage including
billionaire mike bloomberg who is not on
the ticket here in south carolina
tom steyer will also debate after just
qualifying thanks to his support in the
latest
cbs news battleground tracker poll our
poll shows that joe biden is clinging to
a lead here in this state
just five points ahead of bernie sanders
south carolina as you may have know is a
crucial state for joe biden
where his support among black voters has
been seen as a big strength of his
campaign but that appears to be changing
black voters are likely to make up about
60 of the electorate here
and the former vice president is
expected to get an endorsement from
influential
house majority whip that's james clyburn
on wednesday
he told us that he was not going to
weigh in until after the debate
this primary is open what does that mean
it means any registered voter
can take part regardless of your party
54 democratic delegates are at stake on
saturday along with a springboard
momentum
going into super tuesday next week so as
we say it's a very big deal
tim scott is a republican senator from
south carolina
he joins us only on cbs this morning
senator scott thank you for getting up
early and joining us on the table
anytime gil asks i say yes it works
i call and you're hiding under the table
tell her i'm not here but
senator scott let's let's start with
your thoughts about this about the
democratic party
are you going to be watching this debate
tomorrow with a bowl of popcorn waiting
to see what's going to happen next but
many twists and turns
certainly a big bowl of popcorn i call
the last debate the thriller in manila
it was an amazing debate from my
perspective 20 million folks
tuned in why you saw elizabeth warren go
after mike bloomberg
with reckless abandonment you saw bernie
sanders almost unscathed during the
debate
that perhaps is the most dangerous
combination you could see on a debate
stage someone being targeted but the
front-runner being left alone
if things are going to change for this
nation from a democrat perspective
someone's going to take bernie sanders
on head to head
tomorrow night the thriller in south
carolina right there
that's a beautiful building beautiful
charleston center's amazing place do you
think that bernie sanders is the biggest
threat to president trump right now
i do think so i would say that the
biggest threat to president trump is
president trump what do you mean what do
you mean by that well
if he's on his game as he was at the
state of the union i don't think there's
a candidate in the country that can beat
him
if there is a second choice other than
himself
it would be bernie sanders bernie
sanders brings that outside game in a
similar fashion
that president trump did in 2016. think
about the similarities in 2016
republican leadership republican wisdom
said that there's no way in the world
out of the 17 candidates donald trump
will be the president
this year in some way it seems to mimic
this to me i think what's happening with
bernie sanders
similar yeah and the the tea leaves
suggest that the democrat party
is looking for every way to stop bernie
sanders
from winning even if he has the
plurality which i think would
cause an implosion on the foundation of
the democrat party you think bernie
sanders would be the hardest candidate
for donald trump to be and who would be
the easiest
the easiest would be mike bloomberg mike
bloomberg has been so provocative he has
so many uh challenging story headlines
the narratives for
as president trump calls him little mike
would be easy for
president trump to take aren't you think
of the next names do the nicknames
bother you well listen i would not use i
would not call folks nicknames but
it worked you're calling them literally
they worked in the republican primary i
watched
the candidate i started supporting marco
rubio uh be
be made into a caricature yes along the
way so what president trump has that
almost no other republican candidate has
ever had and i haven't seen it on the
democrat side
is this he understands media
everything feels like a a show when he's
on stage because he understands how to
get the audience involved you haven't
mentioned joe biden in this conversation
i think many people thought we'd be
talking more about joe biden in this
particular stage well three weeks ago i
did too
literally i said that with a 30-point
lead
here in my home state that joe biden was
invincible
what we've seen since then is a
narrowing of the margin
not with steyer who's pulling votes away
from
joe biden not with bloomberg because
he's not on the ballot but because
bernie sanders is doing something in 26
2020 that he could not do in 2016
which is getting african-americans and
hispanic voters
to take a second look at his campaign i
think perhaps the primary reason
is health care if you look at what he
stands at what stands out the most in
his campaign is
he is undeniable a socialist
but he is strong and clear and competent
on the issues he supports
and the issue of health care is a big
issue in the african-american community
and i think it is the issue why he ended
up with
51 of the hispanic vote in nevada u.s
officials have raised concerns about the
russians interfering in our election yes
targeting donald trump and bernie
sanders yes does that concern you that
that's
now an issue again and that donald trump
doesn't seem to be taking it seriously
going against his own u.s intelligence
officials i think we should take
election interference from any foreign
nation very seriously to include russia
and
anyone else the good news is uh having
had a conversation with those folks who
were
in the house intelligence briefing but
what was reported out is inconsistent
with what actually happened within the
room so i think we should all be
on our guard as it relates to election
interference
but what it typically comes in the form
of is social media
facebook and trying to influence voters
in a specific direction
not actually manipulating the the votes
themselves but the people who actually
cast the votes all right tim scott thank
you will you be watching oh yes maybe
this is gonna be fun to watch this one
all right i hope so thank you senator
scott
salad i'm really happy to be in your
state today thank you for being in my
hometown
cbs news will co-host tomorrow night's
democratic presidential debate have you
heard nora o'donnell and i will moderate
we'll be joined by margaret brennan
major garrett and bill whitaker
of 60 minutes in the questioning we've
got the a team
it's co-hosted by the congressional
black caucus institute and
the democratic national committee and
twitter is a partner this time you can
see the debate tomorrow at 8 pm
eastern 7 central right here on cbs and
cbsn
and if you would like to include a
question for the candidates you can
participate how
submit it on twitter by using the
hashtag dem debate
we're looking at all of them